here we go
it's epic ew i'm so gross and fat ew
okay well
so far nothing bad is here
how do i get in there maybe i can get
like a
ball to oh my god there is a ball
ah dude people say this game is hard
pathetic
i love how you see looking at you hey
buddy why did you come down today mate
ah [ __ ] i forgot about that god [ __ ]
damn it
i know there's like an area in the
beginning that you can kind of cheese
your way through right
oh can you jump down there
right it looks like zero dabs are one
all right so we're starting up the live
stream here i don't know what happened
really crazy son of a snake
[Applause]
what the f who threw that who's ever
doing that
you're going to be pissed off that you
did that
ow i don't remember how i beat this boss
to be honest
oh [ __ ] jump then you little [ __ ]
how did that know here clearly this
strategy is working out
impeccably very good so far
he [ __ ] turned around oh his balls
are claiming me
he better not be fast
go go go go go go go don't hit me don't
give me
my camera
all right so that's how you do it on the
first try it's whatever
come here this guy's so annoying
oh there's the kick eat ass
what do you learn to aim in rat school
idiot
dude look at my bony ass i want to have
a thick ass it's not fun
all right all right
he doesn't actually go inside the fire
oh he does
he's gonna fall for it three times don't
call peter
don't call peter please
[Music]
no mulligan i get one mole again that's
right
pretty bad
two milligans you get two mulligans ah
what i'm alive no
oy oy he's always gonna die oh he can't
die
god damn stop it oh he's my new best
friend oh my god this
oh yeah this is a bad idea here we go
it's a party
yeah yeah
oh where's your friend huh
yeah thank you oy zero dabs
pretty good so far slow roll is good for
this fight
two lasers and [ __ ] how long does this
happen
is he presenting himself that's right
that's right i'm too poppy
[Music]
double hit ah
no oh oh god oh
oh you can't hit me i'm swedish 15
meatballs oh come to poppy
come too poppy
we have to go for it
so this is where you meet a dark knight
that can actually drop
a really good weapon because this is how
the speedrunners do it right they just
run here
cool so literally he doesn't no
uh how do i do the thing
how do i do the thing
oh
oh i get the black knight halberd we
have the halbert so
it should be really strong let's go
gamers
zero deaths okay here we go oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my it's gaming week
gaming week let's do this gamer to gamer
i feel like i'm not prepared at all
oh yeah he starts off with that
i'm stuck it's all right
it's gaming week these things happen
count them for me boys count them for me
can i just one shot it
nice knowing yet
i remember this oh that's why i remember
it
nine year olds look away oh wow it's a
cute little snake
what an easy boss oh my god
going for the knees boys zero deaths
this place
sucks it feels like actually going down
sewers
oh god look at these big boys
whoa
welcome to blighttown maybe try and
fight him over
somewhere else
that's what i think of you and your
shitty town cool so
we're still at the beginning of this
god-awful [ __ ] place should i go down
there there's a guy there let's go
gamer time
don't use those giant rocks at me all
right
jesus oh they're enough noted
noted all right chaos of cool lug
more like ugly eagle [ __ ] i forgot about
the explosion
it doesn't count if the e girls kill you
this is the first rule of dark souls
can you freak off with the stones
literally
no more stones you see you don't have
stuff where did he get this to know
from i don't know when they're throwing
them it's really
stop with the stones please oh no it was
poison i wasn't paying attention
it doesn't count if you were not paying
attention
look at that oh yeah getting them good
over here doing a lot of damage
big on top zero depths that's how it's
done thank you very much
jump here look at that i ride the ferris
wheel this is epic fun time
epic a b b no one ass literally no one
asked me
and now we climb very epic bush
all right all right
buzz off
ah he pushed me the bee pushed me
[Music]
how can b push how can we push
i'll get his head now i wear skirt you
know what's the lamest animal
ever made that's right ah
no not again god not like this oh shoot
it's okay don't panic just keep running
just keep running all right we jump here
it's cool
boys i just want to talk skirt gang
skirt gang this time i'm ready
why you sit hello
oh my god what onion got me killed
you idiot
wait was i not supposed to kill him
trap ahead won't happen to me
no skirt get hurt
oh wow ball gang
near where to explode i don't know if
you guys noticed but he's bombing the
place
he's bombing the plane
he's bumping the gaming weak
game
skirt game all right i've had enough of
your balls
skirt gang why is his weapon so
overpowered
uh no no we're shooting those
oh my god dude chill oh my god there's
children
ah you can't hit me skirting they're
shooting [ __ ] harpoons dude
how is that even legal
you see that death counter we played
so far i don't know how many hours
but a lot of hours have been playing no
deaths zero death has
occurring has been occurring has
occurred
[Music]
got him got the gamer
what are you gonna do there's a pillar
there that's so embarrassing
he's so embarrassed ah he missed
you call that a swing oh god oh god
first try [ __ ] yeah
what is that weapon and how did you get
it
all strength no skill this is the best
part
big titty anime girlfriend hallelujah
they are so large she's so large
the sad part about this
is that all thoughts must be
exterminated
f's in the chat
so [ __ ] anime i'm sorry
oh no what it died
no oh my god
i was trying to hit patent keanu reeves
wants to know your location
oh god i better bounce
bonfire ahead where oh they checkmate
i don't remember this he's sucking me
oh my god is ever all three of four of
them gonna suck me
oh my god that [ __ ] suck again
you get this son
[Applause]
no ah he's gonna chop me ah
it doesn't count if the treasure eats
you
that's the number one rule of dark soul
you have to destroy oh yeah
[Music]
oh it's getting chopped oh it's getting
chopped
oh it's getting chopped oh it's chop
gamers chop chop chop pay to win weapon
oh you can do a shortcut here watch this
gamer
just as planned gamers oh yeah that's a
shortcut baby oh god it's the wheels
oh it's the wheels it's the wheels
oh it's the goddamn wheels oh they don't
stop
oh god oh we did it thank god
that was close all right
hardest boss of the game here we go
gamers
oh my god
oh god
um no oh god are there other things out
there
hello hey
get out of the way get out of the way
gamer
he's slapping my ass ah i have a lantern
no lanterns are for [ __ ]
oh yes i remember this bold son of a
[ __ ]
oh thanks how about you go first
i'll follow you oh look how much
treasure
that's awesome
why i pushed him that makes no sense i
just got on my way
oh god is there anything down here
oh what the hell are you doing down here
dude gamer get out of here it's
dangerous
oh god i killed her i'm sorry ah
hey look guys there's a way okay
how do i fight nito i completely forgot
what the hell is that bad no not now i'm
drinking
slurp
it's called timing
gaming week
bye all right gamers
it's skirt time
bet of chaos more like my bed
oh god
imagine having 20 yes this blast and
still dying
[Music]
i'm almost there gamer but i still have
to fight him
just go down damn it no
[Music]
are you kidding me
i'm done give me give me week is over
give me wicked summer
game gaming
got to be careful we have zero depths
are you kidding oh you
all right guess i gotta restart okay so
we're back
i replayed the game
[Music]
praise the sun my gamers hope you guys
enjoyed this video
smash like if you enjoyed subscribe if
you haven't
we're almost at 100 million i wanted
this video to mark the end of gaming
week
we've been live streaming this as often
as i can
it's been really really fun and it's
been fun to bring back gaming to this
channel but
all things must come to an end so
therefore
that's it gaming week over